before we go I wanted to play a game
with you guys because uh you know you
are so well refined in your beer
knowledge uh so I mean you look you are
the quintessential uh go-to beer
connoisseurs that also do a podcast
about Bonnaroo so what I'm gonna do is
ask you to identify if a beer brand is a
real beer brand or a fake beer brand are
you up to this challenge ham one and
three
absolutely
okay you think you can get through this
very hard this Gauntlet of
beer brands all right it's a real beer
or a fake beer brand Schmitz
the Sportsman's beer
[Music]
I'm saying fake
okay from Saint Paul Minnesota Schmitz
is a real beer brand that was back in
the 60s and 70s let's go number two
Anaconda malt liquor
[Music]
this is a fake beer brand you are one
for two both of you that's from Black
Dynamite yes it is it sure is uh number
three Alamo beer
real feels real okay uh that is a fake
beer from King of the Hill
okay I need you to know that every
muscle in my body is tense right now the
pressure
well you're an overages I can understand
how's your cut
uh my cat is stressed right now yeah
it's stressed a little stress stressed
okay good A little talked and taught how
about the how about the red white and
blue special lager
[Music]
it's real that exists that's real I
think okay first Brew in 1899 that is
real that is real all right you're two
for three if you want to get uh it's the
only way that you can you can salvage
anything all right so with this final
one
final one
fall out beer
The Fallout beer
Michael you know what we're gonna
scratch that we're gonna scratch that
I'm gonna give you one more because I
feel like that's too hard for you so
we're gonna make a little easier
the girly girl beer
this feels real
okay well the winner of this round is a
Mr ham1 because the girly girl girl beer
is the Married with Children beer brand
uh congratulations Parker you have won
something from Barry's basement uh Barry
what do we have for him today right out
of the video
I want that one behind you